>> ALL RIGHT.
, ALSO, HAVET R
TELLING CNNME
PRESIDENT TRUMPG, ASHNOCD-STAY A
SMOOTHACR-A-LAOR HER ANDER
14-YEAR-OLD  H
REPORTING.
SHE IS RIGHT NOW.
KATE, TELL
LEAR.  THING IS,JUSTISSTTHESICLR
ANDCLTHINGT SHE WANTS T
BUPRTTING OUNCE IN MAR-A-LAE IS.
DETERMININ GOES, ERNKINGUTLS  I
FLORIDA.
ALL OF THINGSREHAPPENING.
THEYTARTED HAG,
AFTERAS ANNOU PRESIDENTLE
, T,
TH ISTAD VERY GHINK AFTERWH L,CS
AGN,S BACK AND FORTH
BETWEE WE
SEE.SHETENTIMES,PEPENDENTLY OF S
DO MUCH THE CAS AE T WINDS
DOWN. >> , WE HAVESEEN, URSE, LY
HAVEOU CONTINUINIT THEY -- TRA .
DO YOU HAVE ANY- DYOANY SEN WHA
FIRST LAO
>> WELS TONUT
WHETHER THERE IS A .
LADIE PRESIDE
FIRSDI G THAT.
ME SWOULD LIKE TO CON SOME OF
HER AN
FIAY.HOS IS NOT
AN I PEOPLE THE TONGUE TYUNDERS
ET CETERA.OUSSAVIN HER OFFICE I.
REMAID 10 OR 12
PEOP FOR YRS
ING AN ESTABLISHED
OF OOUSE,
I DON'T THIN GOINGITY FOR HER.
PLI T CIT.RING I AM HEARING I A
ME HISTORY OF HOR
SO,CERTAINLT
HEPOST-WHITE-HOUSE LIFE
NO>> I DO KNOW SOMEONE WHO WROT